hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about the advantages
of juicing versus blending when do use
juicing versus blending okay okay
juicing is really good in chronic health
states like you have this chronic
sickness recovering from chemo or you
have this disease you're trying to
recovery from that's very very good
because you can concentrate a lot of
vegetables in a very small amount and
drink it it's easy to go down the
problem is that it's hard to do green
juices without fruit and when you add
the fruit like apples and pears and all
these other things you're going to spike
the sugar even if you do carrot juice
that's a lot of sugar and then we spiked
the insulin so that's a problem but I do
recommend it in situations where you're
you have a chronic health problem okay
what's much better for the majority of
the population is blending because you
use the whole vegetable okay and so you
can take vegetables and blend them with
maybe a little bit of berry and you get
all the fiber that buffers the insulin
response okay because fiber slows down
the spike of insulin fiber feeds your
microbes you have all this flora you
have like a hundred trillion microbes in
your gut no actually I think it's a
thousand trillion microbes you have a
hundred trillion cells in a thousand
trillion microbes growing inside and
outside and in the gut they live on
fiber so rather than give them brand
fiber or give them a vegetable fiber so
that's going to actually really help
feed them so it's better for the general
population so what I like to do is I
like to take kale okay my favorite and
this has a lot of vitamin A as
phytonutrients that's good for the liver
it's it has I like the dark green this
is organic get it from Trader Joe's I
freeze this so lasts forever okay keep
in the freezer it's already clean-cut
convenient all right then I like and I
freeze little sections of parsley
parsley is very bitter I mean it's
interesting that both of these our
garnish is that no one eats on the plate
right we want to take this
parsley combined it with the the beat to
make a very powerful bitter shake with
lots of vitamin A and modified our
nutrients good for the eyes good for the
liver good for burning fat good for fat
on the liver and I'm not trying to lose
weight I'm going to recommend myself I
use the berries organic berries you can
put like a cup of this now it it may in
some people slow them the weight loss
down if they have a really really slow
metabolism but for the most population
the majority population you can do a
little bit of berry okay like a cup just
offset the bitterness so I do that and I
also put lemon juice I like the Italian
volcano why because this is grown on the
volcanic ash and soils in Italy and it's
this lemon juice is amazing I put like
two ounces of lemon juice in that shake
okay why because lemon juice will
prevent kidney stones and you don't have
to put in the shake I like the taste of
it and it gives it a nice little lemony
citrus and also it prevents any stones
okay I will also add my wheatgrass juice
powder one teaspoon because that's like
an extra boost of actually a juice
powder with some interesting properties
yes it has vitamins and minerals in
chlorophyll but one thing about
wheatgrass juice is that it has a unique
factor that's has to do with a growth
factor
it doesn't make you grow but it's it's
mainly for your skin it's a good healer
and right now there's some studies I'll
put some links down below that they use
this on burn patients because it burns
the skin it heals the skin so it has a
healing factor for the epidermis the
skin also internally the skin like you
have irritable bowel syndrome ulcers in
your stomach it's really good for that
even in some cases of leprosy with
ulcers on the skin or diabetic ulcers on
the feet this is a good healer an
overall healer
for collagen making you healthy so this
is one of the reasons I stick that in
there a teaspoon blend it all up and it
makes two of these ok these jars so I'll
drink one of these in one sitting I use
a straw big straw drink it down I'll
take the other one put in the fridge and
I'll drink that maybe later in the
evening ok I'll do this so I do the kale
shakes not every single day I might do
them twice or three times a week the
other days I'll use just salad or
vegetable ok so that's how I get my
greens if I'm doing the shake I don't do
a salad but the shake is convenient I
drank it I feel great my liver feels
good if I miss that I don't feel is
bright it's also very hydrating and it
seems to increase the oxygen levels of
my body I can just breathe better when I
drink that I think the parsley in there
is like a real key element so go ahead
and do that and put your comments below
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you the next one hey guys thank you so
much for watching please click the
subscribe button and I will see you in
the next video